from our investigators tonight it's a
story that everybody is still talking
about what happened in a local backyard
that prompted a family to call 9-1-1
about those alien sightings an attorney
who represents that family says
trespassers are bombarding his clients
eight news now investigator David charns
with his warning David Brad Denise that
message is to stay out or you could get
shot we don't know what happened at this
home which prompted now this viral
police response we do know this attorney
says you could get sued if you intrude
you do not think this is a hoax
that's not the part I go into because
that's not what I've hired for Sam hey
Derry says the family in this body
camera video who called 9-1-1 reporting
aliens has this warning there is a
possibility of the injury if they get
into it because this family also they
are armed as well so it's better not to
do it because they cannot determine who
is entering who is the trespasser who is
the thief or who is a robber there's
like a a full person beside it and
another one's inside and it has big eyes
and looking at us and it's still there
the family making that call saying there
were two large figures in their yard I
don't believe in it you know but what I
saw right now I do believe in it I got
scared like uh you guys don't I mean you
guys seem legit scared so I don't blame
you I actually saw a quote non-human
beings since the story went viral hey
Derry says looky-loos are going on
private property investigating for
themselves they don't have any aliens in
the uh storage or anywhere so don't try
to climb up the uh walls or send the
drones keyboard detectives meantime have
gone over the videos frame by frame
including this clip from the backyard
that night sources telling the A2 sound
investigators police do not believe this
is a hoax but aliens and you believe
them
yeah I believe them because they are
sincere they were scared based on what
they said if they have seen the
situation that you saw the videos they
were reaching for the gun and also
trying to see something I don't know
what happened but apparently they saw
something that was out of ordinary as we
reported earlier this month Metro set up
cameras at that home after that family
called about a possible trespasser
police tell me today that there's no
further calls for service at that
address and that those cameras are gone
big question though Denise is if there
were beings there whatever it was where
did they go right and what do people
expect to find too trespassing charges
by the way in our state do carry
possible jail time and a fine and as the
attorney mentions civil cases can be
filed in extreme circumstances now body
cam video and officers responses to
calls even 9-1-1 calls themselves are
public record in Nevada now keep in mind
eight news now has never identified the
family by their name nor revealed their
address